hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play paranormal okay so apparently
I can't get my old say back so I'm just
going to do a long playthrough series
what make multiple parts at once so here
we go
now it's weaker time to disappear huh oh
now it's Wesker's time to huh ah big
idiot
over there oh well that says paranormal
- I have no idea but either way now I
gotta go through the whole intro again
if it would ever load load
it's a Friday July 1st nobody got it
actually oh that name is Mattel Clarke
douche McGee I'm an artist no you're not
and I've come to believe that my house
is haunted all really lately things have
been going bump in the night just lately
and just bump so I've set up cameras
around my studio and I've got one here
and I've started hoarding things to try
and prove to people that I'm not going
crazy
uh-huh well it's a little crazy to take
a camera v's so this is where the magic
happens
don't mind the posing mannequins I
picked those up at Amazon they help me
visualize a 3d space when I'm working on
my sculptures uh-huh some works in
progress over there on the mat who are
you talking to who is gonna watch this
honestly something will happen here in a
second nothing's gonna happen really
trying to show that this is real and
then I'm not trying to get famous on the
Internet uh-huh yeah whatever
nobody ever gets famous on the internet
okay so let's just tag out the stuff
that I've done excuse me mr. mani yeah
don't say bad words uh take so long
oh wait a partyer than that okay so
maybe it has saved some sort of stuff
that I've done maybe who did that who
went bump in the night anybody you want
fess up buddy hot so nice out shut up
poochy an arabic barrel weird stuff
rest in peace boy huh Oh your doggy oh
okay oh that's so sad
and I wonder what killed your dog ha
what was that
you know some areas of this looks like
like really good graphics but then other
places don't so I don't know what's with
the increase in quality but either way
all right
dive into what's going on around here
don't know if I believe in goats but I'm
talking like Ricker Shane so I gotta
stop that I don't know if I believe in
ghosts but I don't know what's wrong so
wrong
Wow this guy can book it I mean he might
yeah with a camera attached to his shins
like that you think he wouldn't be able
to run very fast but man he can go whoa
what the hell what what why why would
that be what happened
turn the light up are you mannequin yeah
okay oh my visions going again what the
hell
oh the footprints okay oh man oh this
game does high huh what that why
let me out yeah dick I got my keys here
Jack's lapis [ __ ] Eddie please stop
tossing me around thank you
it's time for this next fort is next on
I agree I agree when chopping jayven -
hook hello haha that's your so rusty
hahahaha get it cuz alright I guess
there's nothing else on the bottom floor
hi who's walking around up there I guess
I'm gonna have to wait till the next day
to discover more diabolical okay vision
going weird again hi anybody there
this study what the hell was that
oh well batteries are getting low I
better charge it when I go to bed
tonight
okie dokie oh hi wait stop fiddling with
the lights thank you very much so that's
gonna do this thing oh I've already gone
through this Marcus no no you can't make
me look you can't make me look why do
you even have a Ouija board
I gotta get to bed soon so please hurry
hurry up with this thank you hello
who's that
Oh godly things are getting a little
weirder this time Oh battery's about to
die don't die don't want to die let me
up I got I got a not die thank you okay
man ah man it can set themselves up
again what's that what was that what was
that oh man I got like chills I don't
like this game
I don't like it much at all okay okay I
wonder how long you could play this game
for I don't know really
I'm just gonna tell ah such a good day
Wow Oh fantastic
oh come on ah blood everywhere
oh I get it 2 4 5 I see how even the
toilet gah
you ruined it you ruined everything this
oh wait no it's now contemporary art I
have no reflection I'm a vampire
hey my painting okay two four five
for some reason I need to know that my
guy out please
oh don't tell me what why there we go
thank you
oh hello hi mr. man hey hey buddy how'd
you get out there your fish is still
alive this is safe ha hey get out here F
ah ooh stare down you won't throw down
buddy
get out here get out of here get out of
here yes right well I thought oh that's
not good that's a fire alarm right oh
whoops Oh camera going hey head up okay
got deals these shackles
Afiya run away leave I don't want
aah why no bad put that put that out put
that out
oh that's lovely oh no come on
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap crap
crap water went out Oh was I supposed to
see something there yeah okay okay all
right damn it
gob another crappy trash can but that's
not even a trash can no why don't I go
you know somewhere else a rose petals
what's with the road what phone hello
you're holed Hostin cobalt god damn it
what the hell was that
oh man
at this point I would stop whoa whoa
baby
you again Kim I wanna go I want to leave
hotel don't know why Vee iiiiii what's
going on here what what's all this then
that's what I thought oh and you listen
to the graveyard shift
yeah you're outside you're inside turn
off the light
shut up that's a bad suggestion I'm
gonna go back upstairs to the my battery
died I don't want to be trapped by
something up there we go okay
ah Kauai dick I got places to be mainly
a bed and gonna sleep shop lights goob
so the day only less as long as my
batteries do which is about seven
minutes
this game is freaky freaky Oh horn yo uh
yo hi uh guy hi oh hello that's no good
can't sleep now please
oh this is so weird / like I guess
that's what they do
hey buddy what am I supposed to do hello
alright burns okay so I just lay in bed
until this passes or no anybody home is
anybody gonna get that I I'm actually
kind of confused right here am I
supposed to do something
okay I'm not exactly sure what is the
deal what is your deal what is the deal
actually you can know the whole room is
just flickering blurry and Ana blurry so
I don't know what the deal is but I'm
all about it oh ho about time okay
anyway let me escape here so anyway I'm
all out of time thank you guys so much
for watching check the annotation for
other videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye